very much with the families and loved
ones of those who've lost their lives
which is a reminder to us as to why
taking the action we are to stop the
spread of this virus
and ultimately save lives today
we're also reminded about the vital
importance of fighting this virus
to protect our economy while the economy
grew
by 15 in the third quarter it slowed in
september
and remains 8.2 below where we were in
february
we in government understand acutely
the human impact this statistic
represents
its jobs livelihoods and families
affected so we will continue to support
businesses
now and as they recover the government
has provided
unprecedented levels of support for
businesses over the past
eight months to date that represents
over 200 billion pounds
in support this is one of the most
generous
and comprehensive packages of financial
support provided
in the world which the international
monetary fund
has praised just this month
we have announced an extension of the
self-employed grant scheme to march
next year an extension of the furlough
scheme at eighty percent
until the spring cash grants of up to
three thousand pounds
per month for businesses in england
which are required to be closed
due to this month's national
restrictions these
will benefit six hundred thousand
business premises
and i can confirm today that we will be
distributing 2.2 billion pounds
to local authorities tomorrow to allow
them to make these vital grant payments
the businesses which have been affected
all of these measures
are designed to preserve jobs and help
businesses
stay afloat today we have
also announced that more than 19 000
jobs have been created
so far through our kickstart scheme
these jobs are spread across the country
and in a variety of sectors
i know how hard this job market is
particularly for young job seekers
hoping to enter the workplace
for the first time the kickstart scheme
is a ray of hope
for young people and i want to thank all
the businesses which have stepped up to
participate
in this scheme i speak to businesses
every day and i can see that despite the
tough times they are determined
to soldier through this through sheer
hard work
innovation resilience and invoking a
real community spirit
across the united kingdom for example in
aberdeenshire
brewdog has made hand sanitizer to
protect
our frontline anchor staff in belfast
axial 3d has helped develop thousands of
new ventilators
in surrey carousel lights have adapted
their manufacturing processes
to produce sneeze screens for gp
surgeries
pharmacies and care homes in carefully
transcend packaging has converted
production lines to create ppe
almost doubling their workforce in just
four months
because despite the government support
and when it comes down to it
it is you who are keeping the country
going
you who are powering our economic
recovery
just as our brilliant scientists and
researchers are powering ahead
in the race to discover a safe and
effective vaccine
to protect our loved ones our families
our friends
our communities because the virus is
still there
it is still a danger so we
must not lose our resolve now we must
keep focused to protect the health of
the nation
and the health of the economy working
together
supporting each other we will get
through this
we will come out the other side stronger
more resilient
and more united i'm going to pass over
to professor powers
to take us us through the slide thank
you alec
i'd like to start by thanking all of the
all of you who are
following the latest restrictions i know
it's not easy just how difficult it is
especially the second time around but
sadly the number of
patients in hospital with coronavirus is
still rising
as is shown in the single slide that
i'll be showing today
you've seen this slide before we've
updated it to yesterday
and it shows covid19 hospital inpatients
in england
as you can see over the summer those
numbers were low but as we have moved
into the autumn through september
and october and into november numbers
have been rising
indeed when i he appeared here at a
press conference exactly one month ago
on the 12th of october that number
stood at 3827 but as you can see
one month later yesterday
the figure is just above 12 700.
as we know that a number will
unfortunately continue to rise
if infection rates could continue to
increase in our communities
and sadly while treatments and therapies
have indeed improved
more infections inevitably also mean
more deaths
and more people suffering from the
debilitating effects of long cobit
now this week we've had the extremely
encouraging news concerning
a potential covet vaccine and in the nhs
we're preparing to deliver that vaccine
it might feel like the cavalry is coming
and we can relax about the restrictions
but it's vital that we continue to do
two things that will reduce the spread
of the virus and help save
lives firstly we can all
personally limit transmission by washing
hands
wearing masks and keeping an appropriate
distance from each other that is what
the restrictions are designed to do we
know these measures work
so don't stop now keep going
because frankly every time you wash your
hands
you keep your distance you wear a mask
you could be preventing passing the
virus to a loved one
to a neighbor or to someone you work
with
and secondly of course i'd urge
everybody with symptoms to come forward
to get tested
and self-isolate when they come into
contact with anyone
who is tested positive both these
measures
will slow the growth in infections that
will inevitably
lead to increased hospital admissions
and sadly increased debts
there is hope on the horizon with a
vaccine and of course that is welcome
news
but the vaccine's not here yet and it
will not help us
in this second wave if infections
continue to rise
that's why it's vital that we all
continue to follow all of the guidelines
are getting a vaccine so rapidly to this
point as you've heard
uh is a major scientific achievement
and and i think it's an unprecedenting
unprecedented
achievement and and personally i applaud
all those scientists
everybody who has been involved in the
development and the continuing
development
of the many vaccines that are being uh
developed but today i'd like to
by specially thanking everybody who has
taken part
in the trials that have been ongoing
whether it's the recovery trial here in
the uk
which has helped the nhs show the world
that dexamethasone is a successful
treatment
for covid or those who've taken part in
the clinical
vaccine trials for covid and indeed
continue to do so
all of you who have done this have
selflessly put yourselves forward
for the greater good of all of us and
your actions i'm absolutely convinced
will ultimately help save lives so a big
thank you
for me and everybody working in the nhs
alec thanks steve i think we'll now go
to questions from the public like first
uh
we have a a video uh for chris from
chris
from redding good evening
in light of the pfizer and biotech
announcement of a development of a
vaccine that is 90 percent effective
can the government now inform the public
how this and other vaccines
will be rolled out across the uk in 2021
thank you very much great well thank you
chris for that question of course
incredibly pertinent at this point as
we've heard about the developments on
the the fisa bantec vaccine um
we have the independent uh joint
committee on vaccinations immunizations
which decides in terms of tiering in
terms of
who will
access to the vaccine first uh i'll ask
professor powers to perhaps talk also
about uh
how we're going to deploy this uh but i
think that the key issue is
and making sure that those who are most
at risk most vulnerable
who get access to the vaccine first i
think
very very many people across the country
will absolutely understand that
it is about protecting the vulnerable
about protecting people's loved ones
but steve do you want to add anything
yes so as i've said chris
a huge achievement uh to get to the
point uh this week so
so quickly in that this pandemic that a
potential vaccine is available
clearly we need to see the data from the
clinical trials the usual regulatory
mechanisms that that
are gone through for any new drug or new
treatment will be gone through once they
are available
and then it will be the task to deploy
that vaccine
so of course in the nhs we have been
working incredibly hard to prepare
ourselves for this
we are very good at vaccine programs we
undertake flu vaccination every winter
indeed we are well into flu vaccine
vaccination time of year and our gps and
community pharmacies have been doing a
tremendous job
ensuring that those that need the flu
vaccine get it this year
so we have the systems in place already
to build on to deliver a flu vaccine
so our general we will be saying more
about this in the weeks to come
once we know a bit more about the
vaccine
uh about the way it needs to be handled
once the regulatory
approvals have been gone through
so we will set all of that out but
we are working uh incredibly hard and
i'm confident the nhs
will be up to to what will be a huge
logistical challenge
but we have done this we could done this
with flu every year
we will be able to do it with kovid
steve thanks very much
i think we now have a question from
laura from sheffield
so laura from sheffield asks if the
current restrictions
end on the 2nd of december do we go back
into the
area tier we are currently in or will it
be reassessed
um so laura thank you very much for your
question
we made it very clear that the national
restrictions will come to an
end on the 2nd of december and then we
will move
back into the tiering system i think
what's important right now
is exactly as professor powers has said
that we observe the rules we've
observed the guidance and do the basics
to protect ourselves
wash your hands cover your face maintain
social distance
and of course as we get to the 2nd of
december the prime minister will set
out more details but the restrictions
national registrations will be coming to
an end
on the 2nd of december thank you
uh for that question laura i think we
now go to
questions from the media and i think the
first question is from
sophie hutchinson from the bbc sophie
hi um questions for both of you
professor powis to start with
how concerned are you about this very
dramatic jump in the number of
covet 19 cases that we've seen in
today's figures
do you think these people were infected
just before the lockdown and do you
think it was a mistake to allow
a number of days between the
announcement of the lockdown
and its actual start and a question
for the business secretary and can you
be sure
that the disruption from brexit will not
interfere
with the supply chain for the vaccine
shall i i'll take the first point then
sophie so
um i think the first point i'd make of
course is as you know
uh it's important to look at the number
of cases reported over a number of days
and not just take one day in isolation
uh and as you've heard earlier the
seven-day rolling average is just above
22 000. so
uh important not to focus just on a
single day because of the way test and
trace works
the second thing of course there is
other data to look at the office for
national statistics has been
uh looking at uh coveted infections
in in a segment of the population every
week it will report again i'm sure
tomorrow
uh and the react study which is a
similar study from imperial college has
been doing the same
so i think again don't look at a single
day and don't look as
data set those data sets in particular
are going to be very important
because they're not affected by some of
the uh
things around test and trace around who
comes forward the the ons and the react
data
data sets uh look at people essentially
randomly selected throughout the
population
uh but it's clear that infection rates
have been going up as i've shown you
and what's really important is to get
those infection rates down
that's what will reduce debts it's what
will reduce the
pressure on hospitals and it's what will
prevent the long-term effects of covert
such as
long-covered so the real key thing about
the data is
is to emphasize the importance of all of
us
complying with the restrictions driving
the r below one
and getting those infection rates down
again
uh sophie to your question on our future
relationship with the eu
as you know those talks are continuing
uh as the prime minister said there is a
deal to be done
um but i think it's also important to
emphasize is that
whatever form of deal we we end up with
uh with the the european union
there are going to be changes for
businesses
and i have been writing my department
has been writing on a weekly basis to
hundreds of thousands of businesses
uh making them aware of individual areas
where they're going to have to have a
look and see whether they're ready for
the under transition so that may be
in terms of custom clearances it may be
uh how they're looking to employ people
who are currently working in the
european union
uh issues around work permits if they're
going to go and work in the european
union
all of these issues i think businesses
of course
will want to address and we've been
holding webinars on a
sector basis with businesses very very
many thousands of businesses signing up
for those
working with business representative
organizations so they can cascade
information down to the millions of
members they have
and also proactively as a department
indeed across government
uh contacting and talking to businesses
who need to get ready
and i want to thank all the businesses
the very many businesses across our
country
who are making every effort to make sure
that they're ready for for transition
and of course we will continue to work
with you we will continue to support
with you
support you and make sure that post
transition
uh we are also ready for the
opportunities that will come thank you
very much
for that uh questions uh sophie uh we
now move to
dan hewitt at itv dan
thank you a question first of all to the
business secretary and on the day we
again
learnt the scale of the economic cost
being caused by this pandemic a number
of your own
conservative mps are very concerned on
what's going on inside
number 10 following the resignation of
lee kay and the pm's director of
communications taurean peace roger gale
says it's extraordinary and unacceptable
that downstream should allow itself to
be distracted by internal squabbles
what is your message to him and other uh
concerned mps and the question if i may
to professor paris um do you regret
stopping routine surgery too early in
the first wave
and resuming it too late and will you
apologize to those hundreds of thousands
of people
who are still waiting for treatment uh
dan thank you for that question
i'll take the first one um so i can tell
you that all of this in government
are focused on one thing which is
protecting lives and protecting
livelihoods
and i've set out some of the measures
that we've taken in terms of
extending the the photo scheme uh
protecting millions of jobs extending
the
uh self-employment scheme uh
and that again protecting so far uh 2.6
million
uh jobs through that and indeed all the
all the grants and other support that we
have provided um
and we will continue to do that that is
what
uh people watching this press conference
your viewers
will expect them to do to make sure that
we are providing support for them
and continuing to put our arms around
them at what is a really very very
difficult time
for lots of businesses where people will
be concerned and worried about their
jobs about their livelihoods
about their families and it is right and
proper that as a government we step
forward
and provide that support and we will
continue to do so
steve you want to take a second yes
thank you dan so of course back in march
we were at the very start of this
pandemic uh we could see
uh infection rates hospitalizations
rising incredibly rapidly much more
rapidly than they are
in the autumn yeah even and of course we
could see around europe as well
health systems coming under tremendous
pressure so northern italy was a
good example uh from those high
infection rates
uh testing was more limited so we had
less information about uh
exactly where where the virus was and
and for all those reasons it was
absolutely critical
that we were able to create the capacity
uh in the nhs to deal with that wave of
infections
not knowing how large it was going to be
and in fact not knowing how the public
would respond
to the measures were being put in place
by the government
of course they responded magnificently
we know that so it was right that we
that we ensured that the nhs was ready
for that
we had the capacity of course we had the
nightingale on top
uh but of course we don't want people we
don't want to step down
elective surgery where it's all possible
and indeed that's why
in the second wave this autumn we
haven't done that
we are keeping elective care going
our clinicians have done a fantastic job
over the summer are beginning to catch
up cancer work is back where it was last
year
there is more work to do and of course
the key thing here is
as infection rates rise and hospitals
come under pressure
we've seen that in areas of the country
with high community rates
then once again uh there is a
possibility that
that elective care gets gets affected
and our staff don't want that to happen
uh our staff want to get on
treat people who are on waiting lists
and to make sure that those waiting
lists
come down and of course you know we're
all sorry that people have been affected
in this way none of us
as clinicians none of us as managers
want this to happen we want to get on
and treat people the public can help us
with this task
so it's the same message again but it's
it's absolutely true that if we
collectively as the public once again
as we did in the spring keep to the
guidance drive down infection rates then
that is the best way to ensure
that the nhs can do what it always does
which is to
treat everybody with covid people who
don't have covid
ensure that those waiting times don't
increase and that we can get on
and manage the backlog there isn't a
clinician
in the land that doesn't want to do that
we will
absolutely do our best for our patients
and the public can help us uh by doing
uh
their best too great thanks steve thanks
stan for the for the question
we're now going to sam coats at sky
samhain
hello secretary of state we've seen
turbulence
in downing street this week things seem
fluid
who should president-elect joe biden's
chief of staff call
in downing street if he has an urgent
issue to discuss
and professor price with the uk's
failure to strike a trade deal with the
eu
make any difference at all to the uk's
ability to
source coronavirus vaccine doses
sam let me let me take that uh that
question from from you um
so the first thing i would say to you is
that as you know the prime minister has
had
a a very positive call with president
elect biden
and uh he's congratulated him of course
congratulated
the vice president-elect uh who uh with
her background and also the fact
uh that she will be the first uh female
uh vice president of america of course
has achieved something really quite
historic
uh and uh the prime minister's um talked
about all the range of areas
where we have our uh we're able to work
with the us where we have our special
relationships
one of those of course is climate uh
where the
uh the biden uh uh team has said
uh that they will rejoin the paris
agreement
um in terms of uh the focus of this
government
uh as i've said to to dan hewitt at itv
our focus is singular our focus is on
protecting lives
and livelihoods and we will continue to
do that because that is what
uh your viewers expect of us uh steve
yeah so on the eu exit question of the
nhs of course has been preparing for eu
exit for some time and we will continue
to
to make sure that we are uh prepared for
for various changes
on on the issue of procurement of
vaccine the secretary of state has
office of
government have been handling the
procurement issue so i i might pass that
back
um on the on the procurement issue but
as i've said earlier
our job in the nhs is uh to be ready to
deploy
the vaccine and frankly get it into
people's arms uh
and do that as quickly as we can and
that's what our focus is
uh on at the moment yeah um uh so i
think sam just on procurement say that
um
uh i think in in uh really very fast
pace
the vaccines task force has secured 350
million uh vaccines across
six of the most promising vaccine
candidates you've seen as i said
uh uh the uh the uh news that's come out
about
pfizer biontech and of course uh you
know let's see what happens with the
rest
of the the vaccine portfolio uh we've
got uh
uh the oxidastonica vaccine as well
which is in
phase three trials uh but you know we
have
we have some uh a cautious hope now
but i think as professor paris has said
is that we all still need to do the
basics
which is observe the rules and the
guidance thank you very much
sam for your question we now go to jane
americ at the eye
jane hi hello thank you and first of all
to the secretary of state
today a new study by the london school
of hygiene and tropical
medicine shows increasing public concern
about a vaccine
partly due to misinformation campaigns
by anti-vaxxers
54 percent of people say they would
definitely have a vaccine and this has
fallen from 60 percent
do you accept that the government has a
problem with its pandemic communication
strategy
which is perhaps exemplified by the
disarray inside downhill street
and secondly to professor powers the
react study today by imperial shows that
prevalence is still
very high in the north west at the start
of november
and of course the north west were the
places that had tier three
from the middle of october do you think
this shows the tiering system wasn't
enough
to press down on those infections
thank you uh jane thank you very much
for that um
so can i just say that of course um you
know it's been a very long
eight months since the start of this
pandemic and it's a global pandemic it's
something that's faced every single
government across the the world
and of course as i said our focus has
been to get support
uh to to individual support to
businesses and we've done that and
you've seen
uh as a result of uh the the work we've
done in communicating
this we've made sure that
lots and lots of businesses across the
country have taken up
that support and
in terms of of vaccines
of course i think it's very good news
that we have around 300
000 people now participating in these
trials we will continue
uh to communicate uh with people on the
issue of vaccines and then i think as
a professor power said we will in due
course set out uh
the plan for deployment itself so i
think it's it's of course important that
uh
we continue to get the messages out but
i do think
at this to this point we have managed to
do that uh
was there anything uh on the question of
tearing
uh so i'm confident that the uh tier
system
had an effect uh on the transmission of
the virus
and the number of infections in the
community uh and i'm sure that tier
three had a greater effect than tier one
that had a greater effect than tier one
of course it's important to remember
that that tier three
uh had a a number of different ways in
which that could be applied
but if you look in liverpool for example
i can certainly say from the nhs point
of view
we are beginning to see some of the
effects of tier three
and we're beginning to see that the
number of patients for instance
in liverpool university hospitals with
covid is now less than it was a week ago
we will not see the benefit to the nhs
in terms of patients in hospital
of the national restrictions that would
put in place last thursday
until into next week because there is a
two week lag between people getting
infected
developing symptoms and getting admitted
to hospital but some of the effects that
we're seeing in the merseyside at the
moment
will have been the result of tier three
but it's important that we don't just
plateau at a high level
it's important that infection rates go
down so
stabilizing are around one is
is helpful but it really needs to get
below one
and that is what the current uh national
restrictions are designed to do
we will see over the course of the next
weeks how that
plays through but as i say in the north
west i think
we are seeing some of the effects of the
tier three
measures that were put in place in
merseyside great
thank you so much jane for your question
uh we're now going to mesa hall at the
express
mr hyde uh thank you hello thank you
secretary of state
a question to you both about the hopeful
vaccine
have there been any discussions within
the government about the possibility of
compulsory
vaccination as was used in this country
against
smallpox for many years and what work
has been done if any
on creating a certification system to
ensure that people can prove that
they've had the jab
um thank you uh mace for that question
so
i think that the first issue of course
is to make sure that uh
we have vaccine doses which are safe and
available uh and uh we're absolutely
clear that
whilst the work on vaccines has gone at
quite some pace
these vaccines will only be deployed if
they are safe and the efficacy
is is there as i said the
independent jcvi has actually sort of
set out
a tiering of who should get this this
vaccine first uh
and that is the process that we're going
to follow uh going forward so i think i
don't want to sort of jump ahead here i
mean i think the key thing first
is that uh we need to get a vaccine we
need to make sure
uh that it's uh got the efficacy that's
required it's safe
and then of course we'll follow uh the
advice that we get from the scientists
and the experts
yeah so uh so yes i think as i said
earlier
uh we are good at vaccination in this
country in fact we have some of the
highest
uh vaccination rates in the world our
flu vaccination program
uh each winter vaccinates large
uh proportion of the at-risk population
and and this year for instance
uh we are further ahead in terms of the
proportion of
at-risk people who've been vaccinated
for flu than we were
last so so that gives me confidence that
the public
does have confidence in the vaccination
program and will come forward
for a vaccine to protect their health
and protect others as they are doing
with flu this year
flu vaccines covered vaccines any
vaccine goes through regulatory
processes
it will not be deployed unless the
relevant regulatory bodies
are sure that it is effective and it is
safe
that will occur this time round as it
does every time round
but i'm confident that the british
people
will uh want to be vaccinated uh that
they will understand the benefits not
just for themselves
uh but for everybody because
it's by vaccinating by getting high
rates of vaccination that we all protect
each other
great thank you very much uh mace for
your question the final question from
the media comes from emily ashton
at bloomberg emily hi hello and my first
question is t professor powers
and i like alexander has just confirmed
that lockdown will end and when the
restrictions when the regulations come
to an end on december the second
do you think that is the right thing to
do given the rising cases
or do we need longer to get out of to
get on top of this
and the question for the secretary of
state it wasn't clear from your earlier
answers
and can you categor categorically say
that the supply of
vaccine won't be affected by brexit
disruption
so on the first point clearly when we
come out of lockdown
in december and of course that is quite
likely a matter for
our elected representatives uh we will
not going back
not be going back completely to normal
there will need to be other measures in
place
because while this virus is still here
we need to ensure that
infection rates stay as low as possible
and that we reduce the
chance of transmission exactly what
those measures are i think it's too
early to say yet
we're only one week into this four-week
lockdown
we need to see what transpires over the
next few weeks
and i'm sure as it comes up to early
december
uh government as will scientists will be
looking
at the data over the weeks in november
and then considering what the best menu
of measures will be going
into december but ultimately of course
that quite rightly
is a decision for government emily uh
thank you for that
let me take your your question on supply
chains of course uh you know this is an
issue i mean
you've talked about vaccines but supply
chains obviously is a issue um
across many sectors but that is
precisely why we have been investing
hundreds of millions of pounds in terms
of border infrastructure we've been
investing
in grants for customs intermediaries
it's why we're making a very big effort
to communicate with businesses to make
sure that they are ready so they can get
customs clearances done
all of that work is ongoing um if we all
get prepared
we will be in absolutely the right place
post position but the key message that i
want to leave for businesses
is that whatever deal we end up in terms
of our future relationship with the eu
there will be changes for business and
businesses do need to be prepared so
please have a look
go onto the websites please have a look
at the information that the business
department indeed other departments in
the government are setting out to you
and we are there to help so people need
to get in contact with us
uh they should absolutely do so uh thank
you uh very much emily i think that
brings us to the
end of this press conference uh could i
end by
thanking everyone who is watching this
press conference for
absolutely everything they are doing to
keep their families their loved ones
and themselves safe throughout this
process and please observe the rules and
guidance
at hands face space and
i hope uh that if people do that then we
will
beat this thing down and we will be
coming out of the national restrictions
on the second of december thank you
bye